[Music]
as someone who spent his entire career
trying to be invisible standing in front
of an audience as a cross between an
out-of-body experience and a deer caught
in the headlights so please forgive me
for violating one of the Ten
Commandments by relying on words on
paper and I only hope I'm not struck by
lightning bolts before I'm done I'd like
to begin by talking a bit about some of
the ideas that motivated me to become a
documentary photographer I was a student
in the sixties a time of social upheaval
and questioning and on a personal level
an awakening sense of idealism the war
in Vietnam was raging the civil rights
movement was underway and pictures had a
powerful influence on me our political
and military leaders were telling us one
thing and photographers were telling us
another I believe the photographers and
so did millions of other Americans their
images fueled resistance to the war and
to racism they not only recorded history
they helped change the course of history
their pictures became part of our
collective consciousness and his
consciousness evolved into his shared
sense of conscience change became not
only possible but inevitable I saw that
the free flow of information represented
by journalism specifically visual
journalism can bring into focus both the
benefits and the costs of political
policies it can give credit to sound
decision-making adding momentum to
success in the face of poor political
judgment or political inaction it
becomes a kind of intervention assessing
the damage and asking us to reassess our
behavior it puts a human face on issues
which from afar can appear abstract or
ideological or monumental in their
global impact what happens at ground
level far from the halls of power
happens to ordinary citizens one by one
and I understood that documentary
photography has the ability to interpret
events from their point of view it gives
a voice to those who otherwise would not
have a voice and as a reaction it
stimulates public opinion and gives
impetus to public debate thereby
preventing the interested parties from
totally controlling the agenda much as
they would like to coming of age in
those days made real the concept that
the free flow of information is
absolutely vital for a free and dynamic
society to function properly the press
is certainly a business and in order to
survive it must be a successful business
but the right balance must be found
between marketing considerations and
journalistic responsibility society's
problems can't be solved until they're
identified on a higher plane the press
is a service industry and the service it
provides is awareness every story does
not have to sell something there's also
a time to give that was a tradition I
wanted to follow seeing the war created
such incredibly high stakes for everyone
involved in that visual journalism could
actually become a factor in conflict
resolution I wanted to be a photographer
in order to be a war photographer but I
was driven by an inherent sense that a
picture that revealed a true face of war
would almost by definition be an
anti-war photograph I'd like to take you
on a visual journey through some of the
events and issues I've been involved in
over the past 25 years
in 1981 I went to Northern Ireland ten
IRA prisoners were in the process of
starving themselves to death and
protests against conditions in jail the
reaction on the streets was violent
confrontation I saw that the front lines
of contemporary Wars are not on isolated
battlefields but right where people live
during the early 80s I spent a lot of
time in Central America which was
engulfed by civil wars it straddled the
idea
logical divided the Cold War in
Guatemala the central government
controlled by an oligarchy of European
descent was waging a scorched earth
campaign against an indigenous rebellion
and I saw an image that reflected the
history of Latin America conquests
through a combination of the Bible and
the sword an anti sandanista guerrilla
was mortally wounded as commander zero
attacked a town in southern Nicaragua a
destroyed tank belonging to Somozas
National Guard was left as a monument in
a park and Managua and was transformed
by the energy and spirit of a child at
the same time the Civil War was taking
place in El Salvadoran again the
civilian population was caught up in the
conflict I've been covering the
palestinian-israeli conflict since 1981
this is a moment from the beginning of
the Second Intifada in 2000 when it was
still stones and Molotov against an army
in 2001 the uprising escalated into an
armed conflict and one of the major
incidents was the destruction of the
Palestinian refugee camp in the West
Bank town of Jenin without the political
will to find common ground
the continual friction of tactic and
counter tactic only creates suspicion
and hatred and vengeance and perpetuates
the cycle of violence in the 90s after
the breakup of the Soviet Union
Yugoslavia fractured along ethnic fault
lines and Civil War broke out between
Bosnia Croatia and Serbia this is a
scene of house-to-house fighting in must
our neighbor against neighbor a bedroom
the place where people share our
intimacy where life itself is conceived
became a battlefield a mosque in
northern Bosnia was destroyed by Serbian
artillery and was used as a makeshift
morgue
ded Serbian soldiers were collected
after a battle and uses barter for the
return of prisoners or Bosnian soldiers
killed in action this was once a park
the Bosnian soldier who guided me told
me that all of his friends were there
now at the same time in South Africa
after Nelson Mandela had been released
from prison the black population
commenced the final phase of liberation
from apartheid one of the things I had
to learn as a journalist was what to do
with my anger I had to use it
channel its energy turn it into
something that would clarify my vision
instead of clouding it in trance kaya
witnessed a rite of passage into manhood
of the cosa tribe teenage boys lived in
isolation their bodies covered with
white clay after several weeks they
washed off the white and took on the
full responsibilities of men it was a
very old ritual that seemed symbolic of
the political struggle that was changing
the face of South Africa children in
Soweto playing on a trampoline elsewhere
in Africa there was famine in Somalia
the central government collapsed and
clan warfare broke out
farmers were driven off their land and
crops and livestock were destroyed or
stolen starvation was being used as a
weapon of mass destruction primitive but
extremely effective hundreds of
thousands of people were exterminated
slowly and painfully the international
community responded with massive
humanitarian relief and hundreds of
thousands of more lives were saved
American troops were sent to protect the
relief shipments but they were
eventually drawn into the conflict and
after the tragic battle in Mogadishu
they were withdrawn in southern Sudan
another civil war saw a similar use of
starvation as a means of genocide again
international NGOs
under the umbrella of the UN staged a
massive relief operation and thousands
of lives were saved I'm a witness and I
want my testimony to be honest and
uncensored I also wanted to be powerful
and eloquent and to do as much justice
as possible to the experience of the
people I'm photographing this man was in
an NGO feeding centre being helped as
much as he could be helped he literally
had nothing he was a virtual skeleton
yet he could still summon the courage
and the will to move he had not given up
and if he didn't give up
how could anyone in the outside world
ever dream of losing hope in 1994 after
three months of covering the South
African election I saw the inauguration
of Nelson Mandela and it was the most
uplifting thing I've ever seen it
exemplified the best that humanity has
to offer the next day I left for Rwanda
and it was like taking the express
elevator to hell this man had just been
liberated from a Hutu death camp he
allowed me to photograph him for quite a
long time and he even turned his face
toward the light as if he wanted me to
see him better I think he knew what the
scars on his face would say to the rest
of the world this time maybe confused or
discouraged by the military disaster in
Somalia the international community
remains silent and somewhere around
800,000 people were slaughtered by their
own countrymen sometimes their own
neighbors using farm implements as
weapons perhaps because the lesson had
been learned by the weak response to the
war in Bosnia and the failure in Rwanda
when Serbia attacked Kosovo
international action was taken much more
decisively NATO forces went in and the
Serbian army withdrew ethnic Albanians
had been murdered their farms destroyed
and a huge number of people forcibly
deport
they were received in refugee camps set
up by NGOs in Albania and Macedonia the
imprint of a man had been burned inside
his own home the image reminded me of a
cave painting and echoed how primitive
we still are in so many ways between
1995 and 96 I covered the first two wars
in Chechnya from inside Grozny this is a
Chechen rebel on the front line against
the Russian army
the Russians bombarded Grozny constantly
for weeks
killing mainly the civilians who were
still trapped inside I found a boy from
the local orphanage wandering around the
frontline my work has evolved from being
concerned mainly with war to a focus on
critical social issues as well after the
fall of Ceausescu I went to Romania and
discovered a kind of gulag of children
where thousands of orphans were being
kept in medieval conditions Ceausescu
had imposed a quota on the number of
children to be produced by each family
thereby making women's bodies an
instrument of state economic policy
children who couldn't be supported by
their families were raised in government
orphanages children with birth defects
were labeled incurables and confined for
life to inhuman conditions as reports
began to surface again international aid
went in going deeper into the legacy of
the East European regimes I worked for
several months on a story about the
effects of industrial pollution where
there had been no regard for the
environment or the health of either
workers of the general population an
aluminum Factory in Czechoslovakia was
filled with carcinogenic smoke and dust
and four out of five workers came down
with cancer after the fall of Suharto in
Indonesia I began to explore conditions
of poverty in a country that was on its
way towards modernization I spent a good
deal of time with
man who lived with his family on a
railway embankment and had lost an arm
and a leg in a train accident when the
story was published unsolicited
donations poured in a trust fund was
established in the family now lives in a
house in the countryside and all the
basic necessities are taken care of it
was a story that wasn't trying to sell
anything
journalism had provided a channel for
people's natural sense of generosity and
the readers responded I met a band of
homeless children who come to Jakarta
from the countryside and ended up living
in a train station by the age of twelve
or fourteen they'd become beggars and
drug addicts the rural poor had become
the urban poor and in the process they'd
become invisible
these heroin addicts and detox in
Pakistan reminded me of figures in a
play by Beckett isolated waiting in the
dark with drawn to the light Agent
Orange was a defoliant used during the
Vietnam War to deny cover to the Viet
Cong and the North Vietnamese Army the
active ingredient was dioxin an
extremely toxic chemical that was
sprayed in vast quantities and whose
effects passed through the genes to the
next generation in 2000 I began
documenting global health issues
concentrating first on AIDS in Africa I
tried to tell the story through the work
of caregivers I thought it was important
to emphasize that people were being
helped
whether by international NGOs or by
local grassroots organizations so many
children have been orphaned by the
epidemic that grandmother's have taken
the place of parents and a lot of
children had been born with HIV a
hospital in Zambia I've begun
documenting the close connection between
HIV AIDS and tuberculosis this is an MSF
Hospital in Cambodia
my pictures can play a supporting role
to the work of NGOs by shedding light on
the critical social problems they're
trying to deal with I went to Congo with
MSF and contributed to a book and an
exhibition that focused attention on a
forgotten war in which millions of
people have died an exposure to disease
without treatment is used as a weapon a
malnourished child being measured as
part of a supplemental feeding program
in the fall of 2004 I went to Darfur
this time I was on assignment for a
magazine but again worked closely with
MSF the international community still
hasn't found a way to create the
pressure necessary to stop this genocide
an MSF hospital and a camp for displaced
people I've been working on a long
project on crime and punishment in
America this is a scene from New Orleans
a prisoner on a chain gang in Alabama
was punished by being handcuffed to a
post in the midday Sun this experience
raised a lot of questions among them
questions about race and equality and
for whom in our country opportunities
and options are available in the art of
a chain gang in Alabama I didn't see
either of the planes hit and when I
glanced out my window I saw the first
however burning and I thought it might
have been an accident
a few minutes later when I looked again
and saw the second tower burning I knew
we were at war in the midst of the
wreckage at Ground Zero I had a
realization I've been photographing in
the Islamic world since 1981 not only in
the Middle East but also in Africa Asia
and Europe at the time I was
photographing in these different places
I thought I was covering separate
stories but on 9/11 history crystallized
and I understood I had actually been
covering a single story for more than 20
years and the attack on New York was its
latest manifestation the central
commercial district of Kabul
anna-san at the end of the civil war
shortly before the city fell to the
Taliban landmine victims being helped at
the Red Cross rehab center run by
Alberto Cairo a boy who lost a leg to a
left over mind I'd witnessed immense
suffering in the Islamic world from
political oppression civil war foreign
invasions poverty famine
I understood that in its suffering the
Islamic world had been crying out why
weren't we listening a Taliban fighter
shot during a battle as the Northern
Alliance entered the city of Kunduz when
war with Iraq was imminent I realized
the American troops would be very well
covered so I decided to cover the
invasion from inside Baghdad a
marketplace was hit by a mortar shell
that killed several members of a single
family a day after American forces
entered Baghdad a company of Marines
began rounding up bank robbers and were
cheered on by the crowds a hopeful
moment that was short-lived for the
first time in years Shiites were allowed
to make the pilgrimage to Karbala to
observe a Shura
and I was amazed by the sheer number of
people and how fervently they practice
their religion a group of men marched
through the streets cutting themselves
with knives it was obvious that the
Shiites were a force to be reckoned with
and that we would do well to understand
them and learn how to deal with them
last year I spent several months
documenting our wounded troops from the
battlefield in Iraq all the way home
this is a helicopter medic giving CPR to
a soldier who'd been shot in the head
military medicine has become so
efficient that the percentage of troops
who survive after being wounded is much
higher in this war
than any other war in our history the
signature weapon of the war is the OEE d
and the signature wound is severe leg
damage after enduring extreme pain and
trauma the wounded face a grueling
physical and psychological struggle and
Rehab the spirit they displayed was
absolutely remarkable I tried to imagine
myself in their place and I was totally
humbled by their courage and
determination in the face of such
catastrophic loss good people have been
put in a very bad situation for
questionable results
one day in rehab
someone started talking about surfing
and all these guys who'd never first
surfed before said hey let's go and they
went surfing photographers go to the
extreme edges of human experience to
show people what's going on sometimes
they put their lives on the line because
they believe your opinions and your
influence matter they aim their pictures
at your best instincts generosity a
sense of right and wrong the ability and
the willingness to identify with others
the refusal to accept the unacceptable
my Ted wish there's a vital story that
needs to be told and I wish for Ted to
help me gain access to it and then to
help me come up with innovative and
exciting ways to use news photography in
the digital era thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you